it's the start of a night shift for
paramedic team Natasha and Glen for 12
hours they're on duty helping people
right across the East Midlands there's
always always their first call of the
night is to a man with chest pains they
take him to hospital nine nine nine and
as soon as they're free they're sent to
a 93 year-old man who's fallen at home
I'm gonna pop this down here and I'm
gonna step over here if you don't mind
what's your name it's been down there a
while isn't it since about 3:00 I'm
sorry about I'm on him have you got any
pain here hey yeah
Ted has been waiting for an ambulance
for more than five hours hours in the
kitchen and water through there show
around a floor that's great well done
unfortunately he hasn't broken anything
and it seems well can you do the same to
make hold my own that's it
we've got you that's it but Glen and
Natasha are frustrated that he had to
wait so long for help the problem is
with this scenario is they might well
have been ambulances on the way to Ted
and then they've been diverted to
something else yeah and this could have
happened time and again honestly
somebody like Ted is paid into the
system their entire life yeah and it's
only now in the twilight years that the
need is and I feel like we're failing
them
the night gets busier and they're called
to a child with breathing problems in
Leicester 10 year old female but any
hospital treatment will have to be back
in Nottingham more than 25 miles away
yeah the divert to Queens we wonder if
it applied to children hospitals like
Leicester Lincoln I believe or similar
they won't let the animals cruise
through the door got space for the
patients we went in with a couple of
weeks back and that's the way it was
about three and a half hours before we
were allowed in the hospital with the
patient
it's just you fell off the patient
basically yeah
quite often you'll be sat there when
you'll hear your radio go off and it'll
be control shack now for
the more severe job probably no collapse
a cardiac arrest stress he really the
ten-year-old girl has asthma which can
be life-threatening do you think I could
have a listen to your breathing but in
this case they decide rather than a
hospital visit what she really needs as
a GP appointment there's just a bit of a
wait waiting for the out-of-hours
doctors to call back because they're
dealing with so many over the weekend
and it of course it's Christmas Day and
there's not as many appointments about
the normal GPS the pressure on
paramedics at this time of year is
relentless when other services are
closed ambulance crews are still working
24 hours a day and are always just a
phone call away
this man was injured on a night out he
briefly lost consciousness so is classed
as high-priority ultimately we are an
emergency service there we are here for
the kind of life-threatening
and injuries and illnesses
so sometimes if we're dealing with
somebody that's maybe not known their
limits and then it means that people
that are having heart attacks or strokes
I waited a bit longer and every minute
that those kind of jobs are waiting it
can cause damage to the brain damage to
their heart and it can alternative
anymore of a fatal outcome at the end of
their shift they know for every patient
they were able to treat someone else was
still waiting Becky Johnson Sky News